لقاح رخيص وفعال ضد قاتل الاطفال الرئيسي
الملاريا
اعلان هذا الانجاز الطبي العالمي جاء على
لسان المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
تدروس ادانوم جيبريسوس فقد وافقت المنظمه
على لقاح الملاريا الجديد بناء على نصيحه
مجموعتين من الخبراء واوسط باستخدامه
للاطفال المعرضين لخطر الاصابه
[موسيقى]
بالمرض منذ ما يقرب من عامين بالضبط اوص
منظمه الصحه العالميه بالاستخدام الواسع
النطاق لاول لقاح للملاريا في العالم يسمى
ار تي اس اس واليوم يسعدني كثيرا ان اعلن
ان منظمه الصحه العالميه توصي بلقاح ثان
يسمى ار 21 متركس ام للوقايه من الملاريا
لدى الاطفال في سن مبكره ابتكرت جامعه
اوكسفورد اللقاح الجديده ثلاثيه الجرعات
بمساعده معهد سيروم الهندي للامصال وتشير
الابحاث الى ان فعاليته تزيد على
75% وان الحمايه تستمر لمده عام اخر على
الاقل باستخدام جرعه معززه وقالت منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان الجرعه ستكلف ما بين
دولارين وارعه دولارات امريكيه ويمكن ان
تكون متاحه في بعض البلدان العام المقبل
باعتبار باحثا في مجال الملاريا كنت احلم
باليوم الذي سنحصل فيه على لقاح امن وفعال
ضد الملاريا والان لدينا
لقاحان في وقت سابق من العام الجاري وافقت
السلطات الصحيه في غانا وبوركينا فاسو على
اللقح وفي عام
2021 اقرت منظمه الصحه العالميه اول لقاح
للملاريا فيما وصفته انذاك بانه جهد
تاريخي
لانهاء الاضرار المدمره التي يسببها المرض
ذين قل بالبعوض في افريقيا موطن معظم
حالات الاصابه المقدره ب 200 مليون و400
الف حاله وفاه في العالم لكن هذا اللقاح
المعروف باسم موسكير والذي تصنعه شركه
جلاكسوسميث كلاين فعال بنسبه 30% فقط
ويتطلب اربع جرعات وتتلاشى الحمايه في
غضون اشهر كما ان الانتاج لم يكن يتعدى 15
مليون جرعه سنويا اما الان فقد قال معهد
سيروم الهندي للامصال
انه يمكنه انتاج ما يصل الى 200 مليون
جرعه من لقاح اوكسفرد سنويا وتقوم منظمه
الصحه العالميه الان بمراجعه اللقاح من
اجل التاهيل المسبق وستمكن التحالف
العالمي للقاحات تحصين جافي ومنظمه
اليونيسف من شراء اللقاح من الشركات
المصنعه وتخطط 28 دوله افريقيه لادخال
لقاح الملاريا الجديد الذي اوصت به منظمه
الصحه العالميه جزءا من برامج التحصين
الوطنيه الخاصه
بها